each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available um so I'd like to welcome
Claire Horseman here today from KO
University um she's a assistant
professor at Ko and she's going to talk
to us about Quantum pictural for
topological Quantum Computing so Claire
thank you and thank you for having us
all and uh letting us talk surface codes
ad nauseum ad infinitum at you so what
I'm going to talk about today is yet
another instantiation of the surface
code and a way of
linguistically representing the surface
code rather than circuits or matrices
this is actually going to be a highlevel
language that we can use for
representing the braids and the defects
within the surface code um this is work
I did uh when I just arrived at K and
this uses a particular form of uh pictor
real Quantum language called Quantum
pictural lism that has come out of
Oxford recently it's all based on
category Theory you'll be very pleased
to know I am not going to teach you
category Theory I can if you I can if
you like I can others have tried others
have tried but the great thing about
this way of doing it it is it's quantum
mechanics in pictures and the pictures
are guaranteed to they're a proof
algebra so you can manipulate pictures
instead of equations and everybody
suddenly gets much happier when you say
that so what am I going to talk about
first off I'll give a brief introduction
to the 3D surface code model um I've got
a few extra slides I just put in this
lunchtime so we'll go through the
different types of surface code and
where that fits in what sha talked about
this morning and what I talked about
with some of you yesterday about the
planer code there's a whole family of
surface codes and I'll also say a little
bit about how they relate to the anionic
topological model because these are all
closely
related and one of the things I would
like to see at some point is the use of
this language within the anionic
topological model because I think it
should work natively the same way it
does with the surface
code and then I'll start talking about
quum pictural so quantum mechanics in
pictures and I love this um just it's a
process algebra which means there are
some slightly non-intuitive aspects to
it because you're representing processes
rather than cubits but that then makes
it easy to map to the surface code as we
see and I'll go through the work that I
did which was showing that you can use
quantum pictural as this native language
for the surface code because that had
been thought it was probably that the
Rous andorf Harrington and Goyle when
they invented this in the original paper
on the 3D surface code said you know
this kind of looks like Quantum pictural
lism but we don't know how to make that
formal so what I did and this work in
the papers up in new Journal of physics
I made that formal so we now have an
absolute isomorphism between the
geometry of the quantum pictoris flow
diagrams and the geometry of the defects
within a 3D quantum computer which means
you can use as I want to use this pism
as a compiler language for the surface
code because you have a one one
correspondence between the geometries
you can then rather than manipulating
circuits or matrices or anything at a
low level like that you can at a high
level manipulate the quantum pictureis
diagrams and then immediately use those
as almost blsi type layout diagrams for
the surface code which it also gives you
and I'll talk about this at the end
another way to
optimize because within this language
you have a whole sequence of rewrite
rules and you can automate these
rewriting and this these rewrites give
you another parameter space to optimize
over
so let's dive
in 3D cluster State topological Quantum
Computing what's
that instead of doing what shter was
talking about this morning of having a
two-dimensional system that evolves over
time and you measure the cubits and you
reinitialize them and then you measure
them
again the threedimensional
code uses strings of if you like single
shot cubits you measure say a photon
it's gone you can't use it in the 2D
surface code you can't reinitialize it
you can use it in the 3D because you
only ever need to measure you don't need
to reinitialize you don't need to
perform stabilizer
operations the third dimension in the
3D uh cluster model is standing in for
time instead of having a two-dimensional
system that evolves over time you have a
three-dimensional fixed system and we'll
see in detail how that
works this is the fundamental unit
within the 3D model so every point is a
cubit or certainly a
photon the lines between them are
control Zed operat
you tile this in all three dimensions
you have this huge threedimensional
cluster
state so this is a highly entangled
surface the same way as in the
two-dimensional case you have a highly
entangled two-dimensional system where
the entanglement comes because you've
measured all the
syndromes
so um that's just differentiating
between it's to make it easier to
see the white the white and the red are
identical they're just photons you
entangle
them so let's
look do a brief digression into all the
different types of surface
code so this is a two-dimensional planer
surface
code so these will be made out of cubits
that you can initialize measure
reinitialize solid state
cubits and what you're going to do this
is your syndrome Cubit these are your
data cubits you're going to measure the
syndromes exactly as shter said this
morning with the planer surface code
it's one cubit per
surface which of course how do you then
interact them well that's another story
that I'm not going to get into today
that was the first surface code that
came up one surface one one logical
Cubit
this is another type of two-dimensional
surface code you have a single defect in
the middle so this is where you're not
enforcing that syndrome you don't
measure the syndrome of these four
cubits you have a degree of freedom in
in your lce you have a logical
Cubit but if you look here so these are
your logical operators you have to
operate on all of these cubits
simultaneously to perform a logical
operation you you can't change the
degree of Freedom held in this surface
except by these Rings or
chains and the chains go between the
defect in the middle and the edge so
again this is a one cubit per
surface how do you get more than one
cubit on a Surface you do this two
defects per cubit and then your logical
operators are defined between the
defects rather than between the defect
and the edge of the
lattice so you can have a big big big
lattice with lots of these defect pairs
in them and then you braid them so you
move them around each other and you
intertwine their logical
operators and when you intertwine
logical operators of encoded cubits
you've performed a gate that's what a
two Cubit gate is in this type of
surface
code so what the 3D code does is it
takes this
one and for
each Cubit each data Cubit and each
syndrome Cubit it substitutes in the
third dimension so this way into and out
of the board a line of entangled
cubits so you've got instead of a single
Cubit evolving over time you have a
sequence of entangled
cubits it's like each Cubit stands in
for this at a given
time and the 3D model proceeds by
measuring two dimensional faces of this
huge three-dimensional cluster for each
time
step it's exactly
like
this you can think of as watching a
movie and the three-dimensional cases
you printed out all of your movie Stills
and you've stacked them
up each one of them is a Time
step but instead of just having a single
screen you need all of these Stills to
give you the same motion and the same
interactions so the relation between the
2D and the
3D isn't the reason why we want the
difference between the 2D and the 3D is
how we're going to implement this like I
said we would implement the 2D on
something like Quantum dots flux cubits
anything you can keep there measuring
doesn't destroy them you can
reinitialize them you can measure them
over and over again you can't do that
with photons so you can't have an
optical two-dimensional surface code if
you measured this for measuring the
syndrome it's
gone you do you do a c not operation the
data cubits are
gone so instead what you do is you
create all of the
entanglement that you need for syndrome
measurement before you create this
massive three-dimensional entangled
structure and then you consume it as you
go rather than creating the entanglement
as you go in the syndrome measurements
create it beforehand and then all you do
is
measure and the way the
same exact same as one way it's a oneway
computation cuz what you're doing in the
oneway model is you're teleporting from
one time slice to another so how when
you measure a Time slice you teleport to
the next
one and that gives you your progression
over time
it's entirely a measurement based system
you prepare your cluster State you
consume your resource
down you create
defects by measuring in The Zed basis
that removes cubits from a
cluster you create well you find the
rest of the lats by measuring in the X
basis and so at each time step you have
a complete readout of what your
measurements
were and from those you can reconstruct
syndromes stabilizers find your errors
do error
matching Austin's code that um sha was
using can handle both 2D and 3D the
matching is very very
similar rather than having measurements
at different times you've simply got
different two-dimensional slice
measurements so this is a schematic way
of thinking about that similarity here
in the 2D case so this would be
measuring a zed syndrome Gathering so
this is four cubits on a
face and you do control knots between
the data cubits and the syndrome Cubit
that gathers your syndrome for those
four
cubits and then at the next time step
you're measuring the X syndrome so
you're measuring these two and there'll
be another two up
there and then at the next time step
you're measuring your Zed syndromes
again so if you look at just a tiny
piece of the lce this is what you have
over time time 1 time 2 time three as
you go through z x z can you explain a
little bit more of the semantics of the
airs because arrows they go both in x
and z Direction yeah the the arrows are
just the control KN in whichever way
round you want that's it's not anything
other the arrows point to the control
e uh no the arrows point to the syndrome
Cubit um in this case which is the
control no they're diff the x1's so for
the Zed syndromes you have to control on
the Zed Syndrome
X so for the X it is that for the X the
opposite for Z yeah it's one
one um you get bit flip errors on the
Z syndromes well you you pick up your
bit flip errors on the Zed syndrome
measurements which means this is control
Target and this is control Target
control Target is another way of saying
control yes but they're different ways
around on the two diag on the X this the
syndrome is the control and the data is
the Target on the Zed the syndrome is
Target data is
control that's all
um so we have these three schematically
at three different
times and in the three-dimensional case
we would have this unit
element and we'd just have these five
cubits at the back these five at the
front
these eight in the middle all joined by
control Zed
operations so you can see structurally
how they relate to each
other and that's our unit cell it's
exactly what I showed on the previous
slide that's why we have this as the
unit in the 3D
cluster so what the three dimensions
again I I totally I'm totally confused
now who is them set X in the three
dimensions um it doesn't well I would
normally talk about Zed as the simulated
time so think about that as going into
and out of the
board so what we do as I said before is
we measure out individual cubits so here
if we wanted to make a defect in this
lce we would measure this Cubit and this
Cubit and that would punch a hole
through the
lce and a pair of well one of those
holes and the edge of the lattice
supports a logical Cubit if we want more
than one cubit per lattice we need a
pair of holes exactly as in the 2D
case all the measurements we do are
either X or Zed ping
measurements We Gather our syndromes
from those
measurements so you don't punch a hole
in the lattice
first and then come along and measure at
every time you have a measurement
pattern that says right where my hole is
I measure Zed and everywhere else I
measure
X so it all happens at the same time
both creating the defects and measuring
your syndromes or doing the equivalent
of syndrome
measurement and then just as in the 2D
case you braid you move one defect
around another in a given pattern and
we'll see more of that in a
bit everyone happy you all know
everything about the 3D surface code
now so so to breade in 3D you need one D
Singularity instead of CH you need what
sorry a one Singularity is is it your
defect
time you need it basically a tube L you
have you have a pair of tubes supports a
single Cubit and then you move one of
the tubes from your second defect around
and in between the two that's
braiding it starts looking very similar
to all the SpaceTime Anon pictures that
you
get so the I mean I don't know how much
you've gone into the connection between
the two but basically this pattern of
interactions between these cubits in
this
geometry simulates the kitay of
hamiltonian it's an exact we're creating
it's almost like we're doing an
emulation of the Kaya of hamiltonian we
are emulating
anons however it's an awful lot easier
because we can do it in things like
photons
and Quantum dots we don't have to go off
and try and find fractional Quantum Hall
effects so that's the that's the
connection between these two we're
simulating the anionic hamiltonian
rather than going into nature and
finding something that actually works on
that
hamiltonian so this is showing how we
put together this unit cell like I said
you tile it in all three dimensions you
get your
latters and this is part part of a braid
so everywhere within this within this
block you're measuring out in
Zed take it out of the cluster
everything else outside you'll measure
an X and again the size of your defect
here is determined by the code distance
which is determined by how long you want
the computer to run at what
accuracy so the code distance here is
the distance around one of these defects
is also the same as the distance between
the defect pair that's your code
distance you create these
tubes from singular points in exactly
the same way as in the 2D case so if you
want to
start say in the zero State you
initialize everything well you're you're
always
initializing all of your cubits in the
plus State CU you're trying to build a
cluster state so you take one measure it
in Zed that gives you a
zero then you expand out the region that
you've measured in Zed and then you turn
a corner like this and you end up with a
horseshoe shape so if we've got
simulated time going like that you start
off with this horseshoe
so you start
measuring and the first time you hit it
you have a long band of measurements in
Zed and then the second time it States
into two and that's how you create your
defect pair and if you're doing singular
State injection simply right at the
beginning you inject the state there
before you spread it out so it all works
analogously to the 2D
code
so what we have for an
algorithm is a collection of braiding
patterns it's a collection of these
tubes wandering around in this lattice
and braiding each other it's a
3dimensional tube
diagram like
that so
this is a
Cod
um yeah can we this
can we kill the
lights thank you I didn't do anything
yes I know I I was thanking whoever can
obviously hear me um so this we're
measuring out faces here at each time
and time is going that
way so you start off you've got one two
three
cubits and a braid so the reason why you
do the C not in exactly this version is
slightly complicated and we can get on
to that later essentially this is your
control this is your
Target and everywhere that's shaded
you're measuring out in Zed everywhere
else so all of these little dots each
one is a single photo all of those you
will measure at your measuring bank here
it's coming at you you'll measure them
in
X and you just measure through the
cluster like that and that gives you a
Cod so by the time you
finished your target Cubit and your
control Cubit which are still
propagating through and now
braided thank you can we have
lights thank
you so that's what one C notot looks
like at quite a large distance I mean
we've got what 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so
distance
32 when we
go so braing when we go to a full
algorithm how tractable do you think
this is going to
be I'm going to show you
a tiny
part of the distillation circuits for
singular State injection for the 3D code
about between 75 and 90% of the braids
required for 3D algorithms and it's the
same for 2D are distillation circuits to
distill your singular
states that is a
tiny fraction of the braids you
need to
distill
one teate
state you want to optimize that by hand
you want to lay
out the you want to give a quantum
computer the instructions to measure in
that pattern by
hand
you look at
that if I hadn't told you what it was
would you know what it
was how can anybody eyeball that and
tell me oh yeah that's that's
distillation circuit these are all cots
if one of these is wrong how can you
tell we don't have the
tools and we need to develop the tools
and that's why I want to develop the
language that I'm going to present now
because this is too complicated to do by
hand
so that was the bad
news now the good
news we don't have to do it by
hand so we want to optimize we want to
design we want to pick out whether
something's
we need a compiler we need a high level
language for these braid patterns we
need something that we can
automate something that we can program
something we can send to a computer and
say tell me what this braid pattern
does something where you can design
braid patterns for algorithms and
say asking computer what a braid pattern
does look to me like a decompiler
it is can be a harder problem you have
to have a compiler maybe you can get by
without a DEC compiler I don't know well
we need something that translates
between braid patterns and circuits from
circuits to braid patterns and vice
versa ver Vera because I want to I want
to know I've got a braid patent is it
right is it giving me the correct answer
also I do something slightly strange
with optimization I give it to some sort
of genetic algorithm it spits me back
something that looks really weird how do
I know it's right how do I know what
I've optimized to is actually the
correct algorithm and isn't suddenly
giving me garbage or doing illegal
moves the integr circuit world this is
called LVS yes very similar to that what
we want is those tools for quantum in
particular in this case often what what
it amounts to to is is verifying that
one pattern you constructed is
equivalent to another pattern that
you're already have yeah that's a
classic
optimization yes and all of all of these
things because they map so easily to the
classical
problems we know they're MP we know
they're MP hard or
complete we're not going to solve these
exactly we need the tools we need to get
it good enough and we don't even have
the slightest tools at the moment not
aiming for perfection in any of the
optimization stuff we just need better
than we have such a crazy question once
you have a computer does NP stop
you at the
moment that
is unknown and left up to people's
intuition and I I would say it's an
interesting question whether we can get
polinomial speedups of MP problems I
would very much doubt if P equals MP so
I very much doubt if we would get
exponential speed UPS of the problems
but using a quantum computer to compile
circuits for quantum computers would be
a very good thing to
do so this is just what I was saying
these are the three things we want to
use it for
which set of gates is this braid pattern
implementing how do we get a set of
different patterns that will all
implement the same thing to optimize
over let's do
compilation and this is what I want to
use for a language compiler so Quantum
pictur lism category theory in
pictures so this was work as I said
that's come out of Oxford in the last
five years
um the first paper on this version of
quantum mechanics in pictures is called
Kindergarten quantum mechanics and the
head of the group um Bob always goes on
saying I can teach quantum mechanics to
10-year-olds this way I can teach
quantum mechanics to five year olds this
way and they can do
calculations that my undergraduate
students
can't it's a very powerful way of
thinking about quantum mechanics and you
don't need any
equations but as I said right at the
beginning it's a process
algebra so when we start looking at the
elements in the
calculus even though it looks just like
balls on sticks each ball is a process
that you do rather than a cubit
it's always worth bearing that in
mind then you get to the 3D surface code
and that merges together but
we'll I wish to start you off unconfused
even if you become confused
later this is also verifiably a proof
calculus for quantum mechanics if you
perform the rewrite rules on the
graphical
language and you get out a result that
is the same you know that you would get
the same results if you worked through
the
equations I can give you references for
that it's a very nice paper by Peter
Singer and this was my work
showing the topological and geometrical
isomorphism between what you get in
Quantum pictoris the flow and dependency
lines in the process algebra and these
tubes that you that you're trying to
braid in the 3D
model so this is the paper
reference it's also in new Journal
physics
now
so any questions before we dive straight
into quom picture
LM when you say reite rules mhm what
kind of uh size of AAL system do you get
well we'll go into that cuz
I'm to present the system I present the
Revival
um there's
it's not a large system you don't need
very many rewrite rules to describe the
whole quantum mechanics and you need
even fewer to describe the 3D model you
need a subset so Quantum pictureis can
describe any Quantum process you only
need a subset of rewrite rules in
Quantum pictural and that subset has
some very nice properties which we'll
get to to describe the 3D surface
code
so the idea that this has got anything
whatsoever to do with the surface code
because on on the surface they just you
why would it why would this weird
category Theory stuff have anything to
do with error correction actually Rous
and off Harrington and Goyle in their
original paper right at the end you know
just before the acknowledgement sneaks
it
in they say connection with category
theoretic work of abramsky and kirka
they're going is this the category
Theory line of information
flow they didn't have the tools back
then this was in 2007
the pictural lism wasn't developed
enough to be able to give this
connection but now it
is so this is the the fundamentals
everything I'm going to show you
corresponds to an element in a symmetric
monoidal category with strong compact
closure which I'm sure means everything
to you you have rewrite rules on these
elements there's been a lot of ways down
the years that people have tried to do
quantum mechanics graphically I don't
know whether any of you have seen this
one Roger Penrose 1977 penrose's tensor
calculus so this was Roger Penrose going
off on one um going hey I can do quantum
mechanics graphically and people kind of
scratch their heads going this is
slightly weird but it actually spawned
the entire um category Theory
diagrammatics industry that we now
have yes so this actually has
um this has a strong relationship to
what I'm about to show
you and actually
relates as we'll see eventually to the
Horseshoe beginning of a
braid that's what his triangle relates
um it maps on
to but Quantum pictural isn't the entire
family that have come out of penrose's
tensor calculus it's specifically the
category Theory
diagrammatics so yet again remember it's
a process
algebra and we've seeing the
dependencies we're seeing which
processes depend on on the output of
which other
processes if two processes are connected
that means they depend on each
other so let's dive in with an example I
don't want to take you straight into the
um you know here's here's all the uh
ways that you start it and build it up I
just want to use it I'm going to prepare
a bell
state so this is cubic preparation
time flows down the
page once we start getting into more
than two Dimensions it gets fun we'll
see some four-dimensional diagrams later
on what do you mean time for process
time what does that mean that means as
we'll see in a
bit you have two cubits you do this
process and then if there were any more
processes here you do those so it's
really depends it's what sorry so it's
dependence it's dependence
yes I'm I'm wondering about the arrow of
time here or put another algebra
perspective and that's fan diagrams in
field Theory where time plays a
secondary role to dependence there for
sure yes um that's not the fan diagrams
aren't really aren't really process
algebras though no I understand yeah so
this is every dot represents a process
so these dots with no input are State
preparation so the green one you prepare
a plus State the red one you prepare a
zero
State and then what we
do so there's our individual cubits now
we're going to do a c not between them
and that's
this so we
prepare and then we perform these
processes to do a c
not so your diagram for the epr
state is the preparation
procedure so you prepare and you see not
so this is the pictural lism
representation of the E pair 0 +1
one so you can start getting a flavor
you know we've got two different colors
of dots they've got something to do with
the X basis and the Zed basis because
the green Was preparing in plus and the
red Was preparing in zero and then when
you connect them
together that's a gate so you're you're
making each Cubit
dependent so there's a little bit of
ambiguity here right
um You you started your starting point
was to say that all the those round
shapes are processing yes uh and now c
not you also just called it a process
but but there is no round shape for C
yes here this so This Is state
preparation this is
cot so you create an epr Pair by doing
the state preparation and then the C
not so so not not the process is not
visualized as a as a round shape yes it
is it's visualized by these two round
shapes
connected right okay I got it yeah so
each dot is a single Cubit process
although that's not strictly true as
we'll see
later so you start getting the idea
um why process algebras bit too much
words on this
slide but we're trying to find what
depends on what where does the
information go in an
algorithm which cubits do you need to
interact with which other cubits that's
why people started looking at these
process
algebras now in the classical world it's
obvious that you can do a process
algebra for an information
process yeah information doesn't change
unless you poke it in the quantum realm
a lot of people people think you can
have non-local change of
information that if two things are
entangled and you change this one this
one will automatically
change so how on Earth can you have a
process algebra if there's nothing
connecting those two you poke this and
this one
changes and that was the starting point
for the category theorists they were
saying we want to create a quantum
process algeb we want to be able to do
quantum mechanics
locally information flows it doesn't
jump from here to here it goes in direct
flows between them and it was actually a
big deal that they showed you could do
this the only
problem is a lot of the time if you
interpret that what I said was process
time as real time you have information
fly backwards in
time but we'll see how once you you use
this to describe braiding patterns that
ceases to be a
problem and we have process rewriting as
I
said now all of
these algebras that came out of
penrose's tens of calculus have normal
forms which means you rewrite you
rewrite you rewrite and you hit a normal
form for that particular unit Tre and we
have that in Quantum pictoris as well
and that's very very useful when we
start applying the rewrite rules to
braid patterns and we we're not quite
there yet but we can get down to normal
forms and if two things have the same
normal form you know they're identical
that's just a Pro that a normal form
exists not a recipe for actually getting
it correct but not every system over R
would give you a normal form exactly
it's it's a big deal to have
that okay so for example this is the
normal form for the epr Bell State so we
take what we produced before and we
apply rewrite rules that I'll get to in
a bit and we create this and this is
demonstrably the normal form for the
Bell
State so that's just one example of
normal
form so here's here's some
axioms we're using as I said a subset of
the complete Quantum pictoris we're
using the X Z category of observables
because this is the one that Maps most
directly to what we're doing in error
correction
so we have essentially two flavors of
processes one in the Zed basis one in
the hadam mod
bases so these are our basis State
preparations and if you want to prepare
a zero State it's a plain red one if you
want a one state it's a red one with the
pi
phase and we and we've got all sorts of
rewrite rules for how you move these
phases through diagrams but you need to
keep track of these phases here to tell
you which one of Norton one is
it and then we could do the opposite we
can
measure and this is an input with no
output it's the
measurement ceases being a cubid at that
point and the other fundamental element
is a hadamar
box and as you would expect a hadamar
box allows you to try to go between red
and
green so you put a hadamar box on the
input of a
green takes it to a red with hadam mods
on the
output or you could say a green with
hadam mods on both inputs and outputs
becomes just a
red and again there are various rules so
hadamar box takes you from red to
Green this is the first of the re right
rules cancellation rules two hadam
mods one after the other it's the same
as doing
nothing Two Reds one after the other
same as one red two greens same as one
green now we have the most important
rewrite rule of
all you have a couple of processes and
this works for red as
well you can combine the phases of them
if you're doing them sequentially you
can combine them into one process you
combine all the inputs and all the
outputs into the inputs and outputs of
one process with a combined
phase this is called the spider
rule for obvious reasons and because Bob
the head of the group has a thing about
spiders don't ask that particular
spider black widow
yes he has a a large plastic black widow
spider in his office along with a large
plastic
rattlesnake he has issues what he has
issues it was a very interesting place
to
work so we can actually write out the
equations for these green nodes so this
this is the equation for the spider so
all of these their processes their
projections you put a cubit into them
so you stick this as an operator on a
state and it tells you what the output
is so takes zero
n0 outputs m0
inputs takes the takes m0 inputs to n
zero
outputs and M identity inputs to n ident
N1 plus phase outputs it's just the way
it
works and we can use this to build up
Gates well first thing we can see from
it is the green node copies red nodes
and red nodes copy green nodes so if you
input a red into a green it splits it
into two Reds you input a red Pi into a
green it splits it into two Red Pies
this is an interesting one
this is really useful in the surface
code you put a red into a green and the
red is a state
preparation suddenly it's as if you
prepared Two Reds bang they're
unentangled the green node here you can
think of it like this if it was a red
node so invert the coloring you do all
of this in the had mod
bases and now we have gate operations so
these are the patterns for Gates this is
the pattern for the C notot this is the
pattern for the CZ and this down here if
you really want to verify that's the
correct pattern for the
cot this so this is rail one rail two
sorry rail one rail two rail three all
I've done is right down the spider rule
for each Rail and suddenly you pop out
as a c
not it's kind of cute you can either
write draw this picture or you can do
this
maths it's up to
you and we can do stabilizers in this
this was the reason I chose to look at
the red green
calculus for the surface code because
we're all always dealing with
stabilizers we're dealing with X
stabilizers and Zed stabilizers the
code works on a lce of X stabilizers
around each vertex and Z stabilizers
around each
face so I wanted a pictorial
representation of that and this is our X
operator and our Zed operator so we
start thinking in terms of the red is X
and the green is Zed and we'll see once
we get on to how the ltis is look in
this we can start actually eyeballing
stabilizers which is not something you
can do if you look at circuits or if you
look at the matrices or if you look at
the states of these things you can
actually pick off which ones are
stabilizers so we can verify what's a
stabilizer by applying the rewrite rules
that I've given you so first one I've
started
off with the E State and then I've added
in the
XX
operator applied the rewrite rules
applied the rewrite rules I've got back
to the normal form for the epr pair that
means XX is a stabilizer of the
state same here zed zed rewrite rewrite
back to the normal form we've shown it's
a
stabilizer again quantum mechanics in
pictures not an equation inside apart
from that
one so there to be a choice which vertex
you start rewriting from um the entire
rewrite system and I was going to say
this at the end but I might as well say
it now the subset of the rewrite system
we use for the 3D Cod code is fully
confluent doesn't
matter you just do it as greedily as you
want grab any node start rewriting
doesn't matter you'll always I could
have started rewriting it from the rede
upper and you'll
get always get the same whichever
rewrite rules you start from you'll
always hit the same normal
form so let's do this in the 3D
model and cluster States in Quantum
pictureis so another reason I use the
the ZX calculus is because cluster
states have a really really nice form in
it that was known
beforehand you have a two-dimensional
cluster State here so I've just put it
in this form so we can see and the
process diagram for it is a two colored
diagram in an extra
Dimension and we always see see this
when you go from an
n-dimensional physical
system because you need to add in a
process time Dimension your process
diagram is n+1
Dimensions so this is a 3 dimensional
plot you can think of
these As Time process time going into
the
board and it goes up one
dimension we can do 3D so these are the
4D diagrams I promised you
um so that's your physical layout this
is your red green layout so that's the
first face the middle the back face and
then process time is into fourth
dimension whichever one you want to say
is that to see on the previous slide how
how everything it's color I mean it's
it's against the the low of increase of
entropy the great picture
the other one that one so the the gray
one had had the really high entropy
right and and then the entropy start
suddenly decreased because there so the
gray one sorry this Arrow shouldn't be
there that doesn't mean rewrite um yeah
that Arrow forget that Arrow okay the
gray the gray one is the physical
cluster State layout that's just the
geometry of the physical cluster and
then this is how you write it in the
pism and this is an equivalent form if
there is no error no
problem there is no Arrow you see no
arrow and yeah there's no Arrow here
okay so it suddenly starts looking like
it's very
nice now when we look at the 3D lce for
topological
Computing we start seeing structures we
start for instance seeing the Primal and
the Dual lce if you go back to the
original element in the cluster state
that I showed if you tile that the whole
cluster is selfsimilar at a spacing of
half a lattice cell so you have
essentially two intertwined lates Primal
and dual
and we can see those in pictural lism as
red facing and greenf facing cells so
this would be a cell on the Primal
latice so faced with red front and back
and this at half lattice spacing in each
direction is a cell on the jewel lattice
spaced with
green so suddenly we have a very neat
way of showing duel and
primal
logical cubits as I said at the
beginning are holes in this
lus and this is what you get so what
I've done here is taken two of these
cells back to back and measured
out the central
cubits
there I've performed rewrites and this
is what you
get so this again is a four-dimensional
process
diagram and you can start seeing where
your stabilizers
are CU this
these blue ones are the stabilizers of
the lattice they're not um
angles I've I've just demonst whoa I've
just put in which ones the stabilizers
of the ltis are to see you can start as
I said picking them off by
sight a ring of green it's a zed
stabilizer a ring of red and an X
stabilizer a ring of red an X stabilizer
a ring of zed zed stabilizer so these
purple boxes you don't actually need for
this that's just just just to show you
where where yes this is to show so when
you look at this is the correlation
surface that supports the logical Cubit
and you can start seeing it by hand
by yes um and what you can what you can
do is start adding in stabilizers and
you show and you can see by inspection
that they cancel in the middle so it's a
very simple way of seeing what otherwise
is an incredibly complicated thing to
find what the stabilizers of the state
are
so we need two more
elements to show that when you punch a
hole in the lattice what you get is
topologically equivalent to one of these
process
diagrams first thing is we need to get
rid of one of those pesky
Dimensions I said we've started doing
four-dimensional
diagrams but in the end we want to say
this is
geometrically the same as
three-dimensional system how do we get
rid of the extra
Dimension this is where the measurement
of the cluster comes in when you
measure any cluster State you take this
open process graph so it's got these
legs here that you can add extra things
too I've added in measurements these
group green dots and measurements in X
to all my
cubits perform the rewrite rules and
this is what you get and you can do this
to the entire cluster and you go from
something with legs and hatam mods all
over the place to Simply a two-colored n
dimensional process
diagram number
two at the moment all of these diagrams
so
here I've got the processes involved in
each individual
Cubit and what I'm trying to show is
that this single Cubit line here can be
represented by one line in a process
algebra so how do we go from that multi
Cubit multic Cubit process diagram to
single Cubit process
diagram
and
that again we just perform rewrite rules
so what I did was take the unit cell
this has put it into a more schematic
form put it into the red green it's
four-dimensional
diagram put in the measurements rewrite
it suddenly out pops a single
line so the defect strands each defect
tube can now be represented by a single
process
line and we can see our logical
operators so in the 3D
model Zed
operators logical Zed is a ring of Zed
operators around the face of one of the
defects and this is it schematically
around the this is a double defect here
created here and this is the end and
we've put a ring of Zeds around rewrite
it it rewrites to a zed operator on a
single logical
Cubit we can do the same with X rewrites
from a chain between the two to a single
x on a single logical
Cubit final one we can do is
braiding so you can think of the green
cubits as on the jeel lce and the red is
on the Primal and if you're simply doing
a two Cubit
braid for a c not you go from Primal to
dual now remember that very complicated
c not I showed you right at the
beginning that's to go from a primal
Cubit input to a primal Cubit output if
you don't care about where your sorry
primal Cubit control to Primal Cubit
Target if you don't care that your
Target's on the jewel you just braid you
don't need the three plus bride when I
first saw this paper it seemed to be one
of the great strengths of this is being
able to work in any basis you want any
time that you want and sort of uh I
think gain some efficiency even
independent of its ability to represent
things it also it sort of as a language
in its own right is
interesting yes you can pick what red
and green means there's you know the
there's symmetries between
them but this so this is a
rewrite of what happen this is the
normal form rewrite of what happens to
braids being to Cubit tubes being
braided around Rewritten all the way
down to single process lines and it's
exactly what you would
expect it's
exactly dual lce being braided with
Primal
lce it's also your original drawing for
a scen sorry it's also your original
drawing for a scen precisely you can
create but this I created by going right
back to the full latice making that a
red green process algebra rewriting down
this is what you get
out so it's a good way of if you can get
the same thing more than one way you
know you're
right so that completed the
proof that if we want to lay out braids
from pict trism
diagrams all we have to do is look at it
and say okay if it's green that means
it's on the Dual lce if it's red it's on
the Primal or vice versa as long as you
consistent doesn't matter and if there's
lines between the two we
braid simple you can can take this and
use it to lay out
braids rather than manipulating braids
you can manipulate these
diagrams and these are all formal
equivalence
proofs these aren't going to come back
back and bite you there aren't sort of
corner cases lurking there going oh yes
but in one case you could rewrite it and
get something that's not the correct
braid pattern this as far
as I shall be and say this is cast
iron one thing I've not gone into in
great detail which I want to look at at
some point is just to check the
equivalence with the two-dimensional
surface code because in the 3D case
you've essentially got your time
Dimension as a space Dimension it's
there it's the third dimension of the
cluster in the 2D case we're going to
have to do go to space time diagram to
get the equivalence and there may be
some things lurking in there I don't
think so but for the moment this is
just provably equivalent for the 3D
case now we can also start looking at
error correction in this
language so in the 3D cluster as I said
around
each
that's not actually correct
um okay that that um slide came in from
a 2d presentation I do
apologize it does yes it needs a bit
flip
somewhere
um but suffice it to say when you
measure and you put your measurement
results into a minimum weight matching
algorithm that tells you where your
errors are and so you then know which
bits you need to
flip which
means every time you do a measurement
cycle you're essentially post selecting
a given outcome you want it to be zero
if it's not zero you flip to make it
zero now there's a
particular all of these diagrams when
I've added in the measurement I've post
selected onto the zero measure
result I didn't tell you I was doing
that that gives you the normal
form and the first time I presented this
in Oxford someone stuck their hands up
and said you're post selecting this is
rubbish you know you can do anything as
long as you post
select and that's where the error
correction comes in error correction
allows you to rewrite these diagrams
with post selection because that's what
you're doing so that was a very neat
thing the only reason why this works is
that you're error
correcting so we can
show how our error correction is
working this was
showing that any time you error correct
you always get back to the normal form
that I've been
using so any combination
these four we we're measuring out these
four and an even number of them have to
be zero to get the correct parity so
here I've got two measured as one and
two measured as
zero these pies when you rewrite cancel
out as long as you've got an even number
of them they'll cancel out so that's
fine so that enables us to say as long
as we're doing error correction this is
our normal
form so what do so is would it be
possible to maybe I'm not understanding
are is error correction just more
rewrite rules really no error correction
is error correction is using
this going
backwards so we've got our error
correction we've got our normal forms
we've got our compiler language what are
we going to do with
it the first thing I want to talk
about is how to automate this how do we
automate the rewrite rules so that you
can program in an algorithm into the red
green calculus get it to rewrite to a
whole slew of other uh red green
diagrams and that gives you for instance
a whole stack of things you can optimize
over you've got a whole set of red green
diagrams that correspond exactly to
braid
patterns that are not topologically
equivalent you can't necess
neily continuously deform one red green
diagram into another the the rewrite
rules break out of that you can rewrite
things that aren't topologically
equivalent so that's one way that this
can help
optimization and we can also do pattern
checking you they're not equivalent do
they have the same topological
strength that they implement the same Al
algorithm but topological equivalence
means you can continuously deform the
braids of one into braids of the other
but there's no requirement that two
braid patterns implementing the same
algorithm are topologically
equivalent they implement the same unit
but they don't have to be a you don't
have to be able to find one by
continuously deforming the other and a
loss of optimization strategies people
have come up with involve continuously
deforming your braid sequence so this
kick you out of that so it can give you
another dimension to your search
space and I want to do that's
interesting you might have multiple
implementation of the same process are
not topologically precisely how
interesting how you prove which is quote
better given a resource desire or that's
entirely up to people like you who are
doing cost functions and whatever this
just spits out options okay yeah and
also patternn checking so I want
something a piece of software where you
can give it a braid pattern and it's and
it will rewrite rewrite rewrite say Bing
this is your normal form
algorithm well you could certainly
Translate g to into this absolutely and
then take them both to normal form and
see if they're equal that's that's not
very and there is a tool out there that
the Oxford guys have started developing
that will help us do this this
quantumatic automates the rewrite rules
apparently this was started by a couple
of grad students who were fed up of
doing rewrite Rules by hand and keeping
on getting them
wrong so this is a screenshot from
quantumatic this is
your process diagram that you're trying
to rewrite this is I think part of the
fuer transform um several rewrites down
these are the available rewrites you can
get it to apply all of them greedily or
only one subsets of rewrite rules so one
thing I'm doing at the moment is
isolating the subset of rewrite rules
used for the 3D um plus to State model
so you can actually have a module on
this that is the 3D model rewrite rules
because the full set of rewrite rules
isn't
confluent but the subset that I'm using
is so I want to just be applying those
rewrites I don't want any other ones to
nastily sneak
in so that is a very cool potential way
to go forward using quantumatic so the
complete set of rewrite rules doesn't
give you a normal form right
correct that's
unfortunate it it does not or there's no
recipe for getting it there's not
guaranteed to be normal forms you can
get into Infinite rewrite there would be
for the general case yeah for the
general case you can potentially get
into Infinite rewrite Loops has anybody
done a gate to dot a gate to to this
monad translator um going the other way
not
yet be too hard it shouldn't be too hard
no um I mean at the moment with
quantumatic problem is getting bodies
using it and working on
it so I will wrap up there conclusion
we've got a graphical language for the
3D surface code and hopefully for the 2D
surface code as
well direct oh yes absolutely I'm just
saying I haven't proven this so I can't
say to the same degree of certainty as
the 3D case and the proof yeah the proof
is it stands only works for 3D but yes
it almost certainly should for 2D so we
have this topological is morphism which
means we can use this once we've got a
red green
pattern you can almost send that
to the control computer for the
measurement devices what you need to
know is what your code distance is which
tells you how big your defects are and
then you simply blow up the red green
diagram by that scale factor there's
your measurement pattern very very
simple once you get to that
stage and we can use this as a compiler
language that would normally be called
an intermediate form maybe okay I'm a
physicist not a computer scientist or a
syst okay yeah well intermediate
generally whether it's yeah yeah by the
way I have another equival with your
slide back there
vsi CAD is not used to make circuit
boards it's used to make chips
that's no big deal I stand correct
you're forgiven no no no no
problem yes and finally putting this all
together into an automated tool is the
way forward
and also putting this once you have an
automated tool for
this it can start searching through
algorithm space and come up with new
algorithms that's where I think I'll end
thank
you I have a question which is probably
not very
relevant where is the category Theory
here the category theory has hidden so
well hasn't it so each of the elements
in the calculus correspond to elements
within a category and the fact that they
have that structure enables you well
enabled Peter Salinger to prove that
when you apply the rewrite rules that's
an exact algebraic equivalence between
input and output so when we apply the
rewrite rules we know it
works so there are some fruits of
category Theory approach presented here
oh this is entirely the fruits of
category Theory approach the fact that
these are elements within categories
with that structure the is an art of
creating Universal and Co Universal
objects mhm
that's that's one thing but it has other
ises as well but yeah
but every time I've seen category Theory
applied that's been well hidden I've
never seen it yeah it would be
interesting to know uh what the
universal cor Universal object here
which is they might be something really
really
great well I think what you're ask I
think what you're asking for are because
this is so this particular one is a
category of observable and the X and the
Zed observables are your two fundamental
elements so I think that's what you want
to I have quite a lot of references if
you want to go further into the maths of
this I have the paper somewh on my
left yes it's it's both on the archive
and already published in new Journal of
physics which is open access anyway even
if Microsoft didn't have
subscription we have the paper that's we
we've all read it actually okay so yeah
Salinger paper is referenced in that
Bob's
um kindergarten quantum mechanics is
referenced you know the whole shebang
there's you can happily spend half a
year going through the references
there it's basically what she did for
me um and and the quantumatic tools she
presented there at the end uh CHR the
very first thing fam did when when he
arrived and start working with us was do
some extinctions to that yes
so do you have the diagram for the uh
snapshot you showed in the beginning the
equivalent you
know no I haven't got to that stage yet
that's um what I need I need the circuit
to Red Green generator into quantumatic
in order to do that so yeah I I I need I
need a student to do that cuz I wonder
at that level if it's actually easier to
visualize it will be because it will
rewrite um collapse down yeah and you'll
be able to see oh yes distillation the
applications to anic
topological what I would hope is that
your SpaceTime Anon diams are equivalent
to
this I should expect there to be the
same equivalence as there are with
defects I mean just the
bra yeah which means they can work in
the subset perhaps
that's what I'm hoping if you can work
in the subset then you have a stronger
normal form Theory I yes in all of this
um trying to keep into that nice
Confluence subset where everything works
what happens when you reverse all the
arrows that's another thing you do a
category
rightly well this is this is what I was
saying about when they first came up
with this as a way of describing quantum
mechanics locally people said well
actually yes some of your arrows are
going backwards in real time but with
the 3D
model we have time laid out we can have
a braid doing this that's that's why no
no but you can run it backwards you
could flip the arrows the other way and
go back to processes if you wanted to
lines there's no forward or backwards
it's a li just constraint absolutely
well what what you have a processed time
your fining by Fiat when I create the
state I do this I get that's my input
and because it's a computation you have
to find inputs and outputs yeah the
thing the thing I'm interested in is
what have so it's pretty clear that the
preparation and measurement guys are DS
yes oh absolutely everything will work
if and C should work that way too I
think totally well this is this is all
unitary
Quantum yeah
yeah it's all
reversible but um does this also answer
the question we had earlier about this
is tell me when I've become unentangled
cuz you had an example of that so can I
watch the diagram flow and find out
where I went from entangled unentangled
if you're entangled you depend if you're
unentangled you don't depend so this
would tell me along the way for
simulation purposes if I'm useful yes is
that true yeah because you don't well if
you don't have your variables depending
it
could uh the problem is it might be
classical correlation rather than
quantum
entanglement so if they weren't joined
if they weren't dependent you'd know for
sure if they were dependent it could be
that they are classically correlated but
if you said not dependent I'll treat
them as unentangled you'd be fine like
ear with theity Matrix stuff we had the
same case where if it's specifically one
we've got it the other you may or may
not know precis he wants the same thing
thing we all want for for simulation
purpos sure it's
really before you actually interact them
it's really easy when it's not quistic
assumption yes or again you measure you
hit the end of one of the lines he goes
away and everybody else goes down yes we
know okay so strictly speaking there
should be two kinds of of errors here
arrows here right one for for
independency another well there's
there's
um no because what we call classical
correlation is simply a subset of
entanglement that can be simulated
efficiently
classically yeah all of this is working
in global quantum mechanics everything's
Quantum there is no classical world the
classical world is a subset of the
quantum world so there's no way of
knowing whether any of these whether any
of this entanglement is classically
simul or not
efficiently and then for the other
logical see showed logical C like a non
prefer well you'd use State injection
for the so the so you allow State prar
you would change your state preparation
you change your state preparation and
you put a teleportation circuit into
your
lce any more
questions thank
you